I feel like you could go down straight
down yeah see it worked
hi Alan Bennett founder and creator of
Headley and Bennett and I am here today
to make blindfolded tacos with my
co-pilot over there who's gonna walk me
through it I have some rules and
restrictions if I touch it I have to use
it he has to help me point to everything
and then grab it and I have to somehow
build a taco that actually tastes like
somewhat delicious so wish me luck
copilot co-pilot say something fantastic
and reassuring to me
I don't know last time we did this it
was yeah so I think that I'm gonna do
better on this side and you're gonna do
better on that side that's all I want to
say all right that was sort of a
compliment I guess I'll take it
first things first right in front of you
is a plate in that plate there is
tortilla Jack we got that so what's our
meat options look so I'm waving your
hands around like that what are you
doing oh my gosh people want me to do
one of the meat looks a little reddish
and the other one looks like regular
ground beef which one should we go for
you know I really like red because
typically it's probably chorizo and
chorizo is just a little spicier and
beautiful so let's go for that hand out
front they go to your left your you make
big moves look at you okay so straight
down but there is a spoon okay there you
go you got it right there okay lift
straight up a nose kind of violent a
little bit you know just like going for
it okay then next you what what do you
put on a taco next like the lettuce
you're the one that's seeing the problem
I can see but you're the chef so wait no
we should go beans we should have put
beans on first
I actually just go ahead and dump that
tortilla off really yeah dump it off
that's good okay now put your hand up
front
okay now go all the way the left
backwards and then to your right
straight down no to your left see it is
yeah but you didn't go straight down you
went you win an angle back towards your
body you have to go if it's straight
down you go straight down like wow this
is insane okay
so I feel like you could go down yeah
yeah yeah okay
it's either beams or like you know just
mud go ahead and put that on there okay
so oh yeah there you go there you go you
know wait for me and oh okay all the way
to your right too far a little bit
farther out can you go a little bit like
away from you looking straight straight
okay right there if you go straight down
right there but you have to be careful
because there's a lot of stuff in
between you so if you hit one of those
bottles
yeah sure use the finger but hold on
stop go a little bit to your right there
you go that's the bowl
that was perfect that was perfect now
put a little bit of that lettuce on
there is it romaine lettuce is it
shredded cabbage what is it tell me what
we found that taste what kind of like
iceberg lettuce iceberg lettuce she's a
champ let's go put your right hand out
and then go right okay now give me that
one finger down all right now go down
wait wait those up oh gosh okay so go to
your right
no that's not okay okay back toward you
back towards you okay now to the right
oh right a little more
a little more right there okay now
straight down what how did that you did
not go straight down okay I don't know
what it is yeah okay we'll bring some
more meat on it I think that can't be
bad we're still good there's just
multiple types of meat on this taco so
right hand out we're still going for the
Pico whatever may go right right right
backwards backwards let's go down right
there since you're not going straight
down yes see it worked
oh I don't know what that is that's just
the thing right okay the thing right
underneath your hand right now it's just
a green powder up and you are you're not
even listening anymore are you okay okay
go down straight straight is away from
you backwards is towards you left and
right okay that's not helping okay um
okay go down straight down yeah that's
it
you got it she did it she did it she did
it yes my long-lost younger brother it
feels like it I think I'm probably older
than you okay at this point I think you
add the jalapenos right mm-hmm I love a
nose
yes Jalapa nose the Jalopy nose where
are you from put your left hand out they
go all the way to the left yeah
now go up there straight okay so this is
tough like your hand is in between two
bottles and it's a little bit farther
towards the corner of the table okay so
you need to go to the left and then down
but there's lots of bottles you're in
like the New York's it looks like a
little skyline okay be careful stop stop
look at how close she is okay
stop go up go back up okay all right so
go a little bit straight
a little bit more and then of just a
tiny bit to your left and now you got do
you kind of like a reach over but you
got this
no wait okay you touched it the wrong
bottle that's definitely not what we
were going for what is it she actually
opened that up like a chef it was very
liquidy and I believe that's chocolate
syrup and I haven't even tasted it
oh well add that to the taco and go
great well that's gonna be so bad okay
okay so we're gonna keep on going for
the jalapeno I don't even like jalapeno
so much just if you go straight down
right there
hold on up okay no okay a little bit to
the left you're going at an angle yeah
let's go slow yeah okay you got this you
got this add a few of those but don't
touch your eyes or anything after you
touch them that was a little stressful I
felt this guy's chokolate cuz of that
one you know what I think I'm just gonna
sabotage this at this point I'm not
allowed to sabotage it I see some very
interesting things that could be added
so at this point I think we're at the
sour cream poet portion okay so there
are two things that look like they could
be sour cream put a tape back I've made
this mistake before okay notice
different sweet okay it's gonna mix well
with soy sauce I'm gonna go for the
little one okay so left hand out go left
what was that what was that were you
doing a dance move okay go back go back
to go back to where you had it like this
straight okay right there now back
towards you fingers down claw
pay a little back towards you like one
inch and then make one to the left okay
right there right there straight down
yeah you're doing really good at not
putting your feet no just kidding
[Laughter]
what is it it's heavy cream that was
whipped that's basically going to be
whipped cream again didn't you say you
made another video where you ended up
putting together the same on a taco or
burrito like you are really see so the
big one looks like it had one drop
because that's like no it'll mix well
with the chocolate go ahead and add that
in there that's it I'm not gonna do more
not gonna sabotage it that brutally okay
okay next up has got to be the salsa all
right which way okay so you're going
left hand up okay sure
right hand up and go all the way to your
left away from you straight okay now a
little bit to your right
claw and down yep yep okay give it a
little pour I guess there you go that's
how they taught you in culinary school
I'm sure okay and then I think the final
touch is just cheese am i right about
that
good we're your new boss you're in
charge of this weird taco Hey okay so
this looks cheesy like a queso ish type
deal I'm sure that's what it is Ben okay
well let's go for kicks cuz they're
shredded cheese it's obviously shredded
cheese but then there's also a case that
case so it should look actually stop put
your right hand away put the left hand
point down and then move it towards
yourself and stop this is very dangerous
because I'm pretty sure there's like
crickets next to it or something
Oh grasshoppers are delicious who says
that okay
and why me and salty and they don't
taste exactiy at all what is insect okay
I don't want to get into this right now
I think we should put grasshoppers in
them I'd like to go rogue here and put
the grasshoppers in you know what she
wants the lady wants grasshoppers let's
pull it towards you straight down that's
that's grasshoppers I was even I wasn't
even worried three of them okay it's
crunchy it's like free d'Alene you know
this like grasshoppers were there to be
the worst case scenario right really
yeah I think it's the best thing we're
gonna add to this strange dog over
oh she's crushing him left okay yeah so
if you like smashing open your fingers
it really it just tastes like you know
chicken it's like kind of tahini
not to me that's something else all
right okay yeah he doesn't want a real
rogue I gotta take a bite of this too
there was something else you wanted me
to know Cheez Whiz so kind of go back to
where you were if you can I don't
actually think cheese was gonna go well
with that so I'd rather you stick to
maybe no cheese and maybe sour cream no
we got to add cheese and we already
tried for the sour cream we're not going
for more so we add sour cream on top of
the whipped cream oh yeah no that's
weird
we can go grated cheese though okay so
right hand up oh sorry that's my bad
left hand up duh let's go a little bit
to your left you're actually in a pretty
good spot okay so a little bit farther
and then a little bit to the left take
it to step over to the left there we go
and then towards you now the thing is
there are three bottles and it's
definitely mustard ketchup in like
raspberry sauce so wait no there's a
white bottle - okay so point down okay
finger yeah if you go right there
you should be good but you need to make
sure that yeah just like that just like
that right there all right
whoo you're not getting us with the
raspberry sauce we already made this
disgusting thing I kind of think that's
it that is a fat taco so let's let's go
through it real quick so there's meat
there's lettuce salsa Pico cream whipped
cream chocolate sauce and jalapenos and
cheese and grasshop I'm just saying
fried dress always kind of a much Donna
goes up all right you ready to try this
taco hey hey hey hey hey there's not how
teams work well together look at what we
made look at that he really is pretty
sure I'm older than her I don't know we
haven't talked about it but if you look
you can see the grasshoppers you gonna
try it first
nope I don't want to try it at all it
was your invention mmm I don't know you
touch the little brother house not the
worst taco I'm ever on your brownies Oh
Oh your bomb I'm at big taco
[Music]
[Music]